I finally got my stuff name TV some
people might think that's selling out or
whatever but I don't really give a
that's great to me I'm proud of myself
we've always lived outcasts it's kind of
cool this is what's gonna make us great
in the future I don't know what the word
potential means cuz potential that's a
gap that mean that's a you stop that's a
wall I wanted my own Network I wanted to
put I wanted to do something cool and
it's always about just me doing
something that I think is awesome he's
an American rapper record producer and
music video director he rose to
prominence as the leader and co-founder
of the alternative hip hop collective
Odd Future he has his own clothing
company called golf Wang and his own
streaming company called golf media he's
Tyler the Creator and here is my take on
his top ten rules for success rule
number eight is my personal favorite I
make sure to stick around although to
the end for some special bonus clips
also as he's talking if he says
something that really resonates with you
please leave in the comments below and
put quotes around it to other people can
be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
you
greatness is a different definition of
different people greatness to me is when
I land that and fakey half-cab Hill on
my skateboard greatness is the song I
recorded last week somebody might not
find that great but it's great to me and
that's all that matters
with the coffee in my head as long as I
like it that's all that matters
greatness to me is finally getting my
video MTV it's on there now and I'm I'm
happy I finally got my stuff
MTV some people might think that's
selling out or whatever but I don't
really give a that's great to me I'm
proud of myself
I've been one that since I was seven
years old and I finally got that the
hard work pays off
I love your class smiles and goes
nothing weird and it's kind of like I'm
always been an outcast who they never
knew me I know about having if you went
to the music or just us in general like
he made me a person I'm just serious now
but I'm always joking around I'm
surprised I've sat down still this we've
always live outcasts
it's kind of cool this is what's gonna
make us great in the future that they
hear today throughout a lot of jokes or
ghoulish remember there's always be
yourself that's when one thing I'm like
just do what you like that's what I try
to tell people just to do with the play
one compress another's and that's why at
the end of the day I'm always going to
make the music I want to make
you get so caught up like making a first
out of my battery light was pretty
successful the people are like probably
make something like that I can't its
progression I'm in a whole different say
I'm having a penny right now doesn't
have a mention a year ago so I'm gonna
make the music that I want to make now
that sounds good to me
no I might even do coke I'm a drug
addict two years from now making some
off-the-wall music I'm in today I'm
gonna I think that's one of the Mary the
market when you think about catalog when
you're going to do Cherry Bomb the album
are you thinking now like man I got so
much out there that not that you're in
competition with yourself but is there
an expectation is there is there
pressure and and what's the problem
going into and I just try to be better
than most I just try I just try to make
the music that I look it's like songs
that I'm like damn I will never make a
song better than that I would never make
a song better than Stevie Wonder's where
were you when I need you mm-hmm
so I always use that like god dang I
have to make something good like that
and that's what pushes me and the fact
that I in my own head I think I will
never make something as good as the song
that I love will always and that's your
something that's a definite never grasp
it so I'll always push myself that's why
I don't know what the word potential
means cause potential that's a gap that
I mean that's a you stop that's a wall I
don't know what that means so I'll
always push myself harder whether people
like it or not at least for me I'm
trying things and trying to be better
you know well when I was younger about
let's say 16 17 18 19 I was more
creating worlds and characters and you
know I would read a lot it like just
because me liking to learn mm-hmm I
would read about certain people and then
just try to get in their head and see
what how they were write a song and then
now I kind of just write about my life
like I have a song called hair blows on
the new album that is just talking about
I like when this girl hair blows in the
car and that's I wrote that because I
was with a female friend of mine and we
were in my car and she was hanging out
the sunroof and her hair was blowing and
I felt like the man and I wrote a song
about it and um I think a lot of artists
kind of mess up because you don't know
much about them after a certain point in
time so I try to just I realized none of
my music will sound the same if I just
write songs but she actually about my
life is every two years here should not
be in the same same place what it does
take some courage though to be still
transparent about your own life a lot of
people aren't honest you're they're not
comfortable with themselves that's right
so that's why you have a bunch of songs
about the same things on the radio
because one it's comforting to the to a
simple listener and two people just
aren't comfortable with themselves
they're not easy they're not if I was
like hey I'm depressed you'll be like
wow but cuz a lot of people won't be
able to do that or tell you what they
like and stand for it and why they won't
like it yeah and that goes again with a
lot of people being closed-minded are
you gonna get paid up front from this
from Lourdes Lourdes we're gonna cut you
a check
am I getting paid up front of this you
can get you get your check I don't know
but it's not a it's not about it's not
about money for me like it's not it's
not I wanted to do I wanted my own
Network I wanted to put I wanted to do
something cool and it's always about
just me doing something that I think is
awesome and the money will come I'm not
I'm not worried about that that'll
that'll come when the universe decide
for it to come I live in a society where
a lot of people are followers and they
can you know make their set opinions
like I have friends going to college for
stuff that their parents want them to go
for and they're not even happy or
anything but they're just trying to
please them and in the long run like I
mean what's what's gonna be there your
parents your parents dying you're just
stuck there like paying debt paying debt
for something that you didn't even want
to learn in the first place so I just
try to tell people to just think for
themselves and they'll be way happier
alone
he's Tyler DJ Skee and uh that was a
carnival mm where your carnival was
tonight how I feel is fourth one mm-hmm
do you think that you did it would grow
to be something no he was gonna cancel
it this year
but we didn't we was literally like
getting in we did it and then a lot of
people came are we gonna cancel it I
don't know we couldn't find anyone to
perform it was just such like a cuz
we're like specific or how we like
wanted who we want it they're like
things like that and we didn't come up
with the perfect thing and it was just a
depressing time and we was about to say
it until we was like what do we do it
like where's our spirit and we just we
ran it back in does our biggest we dummy
doubled up since last year it's crazy
how for you youth you've got a deal on
Cartoon Network that's Time Warner
you've got a deal with Sony you you've
used this apparatus even though you're
only 23 you've used this existing system
to build up your profile do you think
you could start literally without any of
the support system and create yourself
yeah of course because that's that's how
I started like the way that I got famous
was me going on tumblr and creating my
own website and just putting things out
like that with the strategic you know it
had a strategy to it but putting our
music for free and that's how it got
known and the next thing I know Sony's
like hey we'll give you a bunch of money
to do X oh no we just a little bit and
I've used them to my advantage in the
same way that I've used other things you
know to my van they didn't make it
no not at all you know so I know how to
I know how to do this without you know
those platforms and and another thing is
the fun thing about this is I'm not we
in our squad we're not afraid to fail
like we're not scared of failing or
whatever so we're learning as we go so
maybe this maybe this doesn't work out
but it'll be a learning experience and
that'll help other people look at the
most of the mistakes we made and figure
out what they're trying to do
I don't know about trying to make what I
think people will like you know it I
think because it doesn't sound like one
full album from top to bottom people
disregard it because it's all over the
place people think it's messy or chaotic
but I think it's beautiful chaos and
it's perfect then it's my favorite album
to date regardless of what anyone says
and um I can understand why people don't
like it it's different
and sometimes different doesn't equal
good to some people but I love it and um
you know that's great that's all that
matters to me if you if you make
something you 100% love and everyone
loves it that's a win-win that's great
if you have something that you really
love and everyone makes it at least you
love it and you just move on
you've been successful for a few years
now how do you have you ever had a
regular job I worked at uh I worked at
Starbucks and FedEx and oh my god
horrible oh what's it really bad uh
Starbucks was cool because I stole
cheese danishes every day a FedEx was so
depressing it was just the spirit
they're just older dudes like just
pushing boxes but ok with it and it it
scared the living hell out of me so I
quit after a week in four days how long
did you work at Starbucks uh two and a
half years and this lady named Cindy she
was a new manager she hated on me and
she fired me and I hope she's watching
cuz I still hate her
[Applause]
[Music]
I hate you see
is Cindy aware of your success I hope
and I opened her firing me was the
greatest moment of my life wasn't really
uh my change was free Wow how did she do
it she sit you down and say it's not how
to go somebody one of the shift managers
warned me like 10 minutes before she
fired me so I had 9 minutes to call my
mom asking her what I should do
oh yeah it was tight I didn't even like
somebody was like yo you getting fired
in nine minutes boy and what is you what
did your mom tell you to do first she
was gonna sue to start she's gonna soon
start but he figured out they did
nothing wrong
[Music]
that's no reason not to sue the phone so
okay that was nine minutes that would
saw I had about four minutes left to
figure out what to do so I manned up and
said all right I'll get fired and I ate
like brie cheese danish
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because 365 days asked
me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you weren't made of
profile next leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I also love
to know which of the top 10 rules had
the biggest impact on you on why what
are you going to change in your business
or your life after watching this video
leave in the comments I'm going to join
in the discussion finally I want to give
a quick shout-out to best you pro thank
you so much for picking up a cup of my
book and tweeting that awesome picture I
hope you enjoy the book enjoy reading it
and have a great time with it so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
music soft feeling and I think a lot of
people are forgiving that a lot of
people especially in rap it's either
like for the most part people were like
where's the deep lyrics what does he
mean I wanted any substance but a lot of
things are filling that's why even
though I'm not a fan of like a lot of
like the popular maybe trap music or
whatever it's all filling it feels good
so what they saying is just a good
filling in at least on my album every
song is like a photo for me every song
is like a moment it's a mood you know
it's blow my load is two minutes of just
yeah and that's what it sounds that's
the score for that every song for me is
a score for moments but it's visual to
you yeah I'm very so 2-seater that's
what it sounds like driving from
Hollywood to where I live during the
sunset in LA that's actually my car
noise I recorded on my phone that's
that's what it everything I'm talking
about on that song is real life doing a
hundred on the street but it's okay cuz
my car isn't stock my brakes are good
like Cherry Bomb the song the crazy one
that's what it sounds like when I'm in
mosh pits and it sounds like you know
death camp sounds like that okada the
last song sounds like that moment when
you're with someone that you really like
and time doesn't matter and you're just
enjoying company and you just like we
should just leave this place and just
for comeback Schmucker sounds like God
and like God like I'm the man like keep
the Oh sounds like this this is keep the
O's this is that right there this right
here but skating down the street with
bats will keep the whole sounds like and
my verse on there is about knowing I
could lose all of this and I need to
make sure I'm focused that's always in
the back of my mind
young sounds like being in a sunflower
field that's why it's a video yeah the
brown stains what cue sounds like a
Sherm that's what PCP sounds like when
the [ __ ] flips like that's why is just
chilling and it
not in nowhere it's boring that's the
feeling of it and a lot of people are
forgetting what feeling is only once
deep lyrics or some bullsh that is
filling every song I make is a movie you
know people don't some people just like
think I'm Liz I'm talking about rape all
the time but they don't really listen
that every song I got like the song
blood I just said in another interview
like that's from the mind of a Ted Bundy
like the way he got females with his
charm and the way that the smooth way
that he got it like he was so slick with
it and I wrote that song from his mind
state and if you listen every song that
I make is exactly like a movie so
hopefully when you go home and you
listen a bastard or anything just
division it as a movie and a storyline
in your head and you'll get how cool it
is and it's not just me talking about
random even though it is just me talking
about random few things that have
inspired you lately I know you guys
don't have just like one genre one form
of inspiration to be better than
everyone because I hate everyone and I
want to be better than them and I want
them to know that so I'm coming for
Kanye was his head because he's my
competition